this right here is a fresco by raphael
of plato hanging out with his best
student aristotle and you may or may not
know that these two fellows along with
plato's teacher socrates are considered
kind of the fathers of western
philosophy but that's not what this
video is about i'm just this is actually
just a small little video about
different dates or maybe a better way to
think about it different ways to
specify dates or dating mechanisms
and so if you were to look up if you
were to look up plato's birth well you
might get either 428 or 427 but we'll go
with 428. if you were to look up plato's
birth
plato's birth you might see it written
as 428
bc
or you might see it written as 428
b
c
e
and the natural question is well what's
the difference here they both have a bc
but this one has an e it's the same year
right now
and the answer is is that these are
referring to the exact same year in
history but the acronyms here do stand
for different things bc literally stands
for before christ before christ so if
the date is written 4 28 bc the
implication is is that this is 428 years
before the birth of christ we'll see
that we'll see in a second that that's
not exactly right but that's what the
implication is
if someone writes bce they're saying
something very different the b still
stands for before
so the b
still stands for before
but the c e the c in ce does not stand
for christ anymore it now stands for
common and so the ce part
the ce part is common error
common
common error
even though it's not referring to christ
anymore and this kind of this kind of
the intention here so that it's it's i
guess less religious than the term
before christ is still kind of putting
an importance on christ's birth because
it's saying that the common era is the
time period after the birth of christ
which we'll see in a second isn't
exactly right but so but there's
essentially the same exact dating scheme
one with a
not directly referring to christ one
that is
directly referring to christ similarly
similarly this right here is a painting
of christopher columbus and if you were
to look up in history book so you know
when was his first voyage and did he
show up in the and when did he first
show up in the new world finding an
island in the bahamas
you would see it written as either 1492
or ad
1492 or
c
c e and once again these are all
referring to the same year just using
different
acronyms one of them's a little bit more
religious or more directly refers to
christ and one is a little less
religious
so a.d some people think it refers to
after death it does not refer to after
death because if you think about it if
you have years before the birth of
christ and if you started if you started
numbering after his death what would you
how would you number the years during
his life so a d does not stand for after
death it stands for
ano
ano domini
domini which literally means ano means
year and domini means lord or the lord
so it's the year of the lord or the year
of our lord
so it's years since and and one anody
would be the year of jesus christ's
birth so not after death it stands for
anno domini but literally year of our
lord so years since that jesus was born
with year one being the the the uh
implicitly starting with his birth and
we'll see in a second that's not exactly
right c
stands for common era
common
era
once again 1ce is the same thing as ad1
sometimes we now write instead of
writing ad1492 we'll write 1492 a.d all
referring to the exact same thing
now all of these things refer to all of
the you know when we say 428 bc it
implies 428 years before the birth of
christ 14 92 80 that's in the year of
our lord 1492 it implies
1492 years since the birth of christ
but the reality is is that we're not
really quite sure when christ was born
and so these aren't exactly so if we you
know columbus didn't sail didn't sail
across the atlantic exactly 1492 years
after the birth of christ most
historians put the birth of christ at 7
to 2
bc or bce depending on how you want to
view it remember bc is before christ
which is a little ironic because we're
talking about the actual birth of christ
bce is before the common era
and they put his death at 30 to 36 a.d
which is 30 to 36 in the year of our
lord or
that's what it stands for anno domini or
in the common era ce
now some people they obviously don't
like bc they don't like the bc
ad naming mechanism because it's
explicitly referring to christ and every
year it makes christ the central figure
in all of history so they'll say that
this is clearly too christian
too christian
and they would
they would prefer the situation they
would prefer the less christian naming
scheme where you use b c e
and and
c e
but a lot of people would still say hey
look okay you changed well you know
first of all some christians wouldn't
like this that you removed the direct
references to the birth of christ or
being in the year
the years since christ's birth
but even here and they'll say hey this
you know you've removed it but even here
some people would complain that although
you've made the direct reference that
this is saying comment before the common
era and the common error
even though you've removed the direct
reference it still makes christ's birth
the central thing in all of history but
this is the convention whether you know
people like it or not
we've kind of in order to to have the
same reference point it would be too
logistically difficult to switch at this
time everyone has essentially settled on
this and it's really just a matter of
of of of letters of which which naming
scheme you pick but the whole point of
this video is that you don't get
confused between bc and bce you don't
think that a d stands for after death it
stands for anno domini in the year of
the lord or the year of our lord
and ce stands for common era but this
and this are referring to essentially
the same count
after christ
after the birth of christ or this
theoretical birth of christ which we
don't really know when it actually
happened it probably did not happen in
on at the beginning of 1ad or 1ce
and these two things
these two things both also refer to the
same direction in the timeline one last
thing i want to point out is is that
there is no year zero so if you kind of
take these if you if you take either of
these naming schemes
you have so let's go very close to the
years one
so there's just some point this
theoretical birth of christ which was
probably not the actual birth of christ
but at that theoretical point
right at that
so new year's
so you have kind of a you know
december 31st of of the previous year
all of a sudden now you are on january
1st of
a d
a d or
c e depending on how you want to refer
to it and the year before that the year
before that was
was 1 was 1 bc
1 bc or bce depending on how you want to
refer to it so there is no year 0 in
this scheme
and then the last thing i want to
emphasize and it might be obvious to you
is the larger a number you have here the
further back you're going in time
because this is saying how many years
before this theoretical birth of christ
and obviously larger numbers here you
have here this is the further you're
going off into the future and if you
wanted to figure out how many years
passed between plato's birth and
columbus sailing across the atlantic to
uh to to find the new world
you would say well look it took 428
years to go from plato's birth to this
theoretical birth of christ and then
it's the you have another 1492 years to
wait until columbus gets his ship
together so the total number of years
would be
i'll do it right over here 428 years to
get to christ from plato's birth and
then you have another 1492
years to wait for columbus so let's see
8 plus 2 that is 10. as you could see i
just wanted to add a little arithmetic
in this video
so 1 plus 2 plus 9 is 12
and then we have 9 1 plus 4 plus 4. so 1
920 years between plato's birth and and
columbus sailing across the atlantic